[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who has
planted himself like a tree
and said no you accept that the power
broker is mephisto
the enigmatic new villain of falcon in
the winter soldier is slowly becoming
the series most mysterious man
or woman and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down all the best
theories over who this could be
and the characters origins in the comics
now because of this there might be some
spoilers here
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
also smash that thumbs up button if you
enjoy the video
and don't forget to drop your comments
below on who you think it is
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the power broker
now though the mcu doesn't adapt the
comic stories in a way that makes it
easy to predict exactly what's going to
happen
we can look at the source material to
see how things originally ended up going
in order to add some basis to our
predictions in the comics the power
broker's name has been taken on by
several characters
and at one point it was even an entire
organization
made up of mad scientists and
businessmen now in the comics the power
broker was firstly named curtis jackson
no not that one and he was basically a
businessman that saw profit in
superheroes
the villain worked with many people the
most notable of these being dr carl
maylis
a mad scientist that experimented in
genetic mutation
and human augmentation under the name
power broker incorporated the pair
carried out several experiments on the
general population
this included john walker whom was
supplied with super soldier serum
and this led to him becoming the villain
super patriot before he went on to take
on the monaco u.s
agent their work was extremely dangerous
and risky
and most of the people that were
experimented on either ended up dead or
deformed
they ruined more lives than i did when i
spoiled the ending of avengers end game
and yeah i do i do still feel a bit bad
about that
now power broker inc was supposed to be
a metaphor for the commercialization of
superpowered people
and it showed how their deeds could be
turned into big bucks
rather than doing things for the good of
humanity it all just became
one big industry in order for people
like the power broker to make money
i do find this quite funny as superhero
movies in general
have sort of become this thing in which
almost every single property is getting
adapted
so that movie studios can milk it more
than i milk theory videos
and almost all of the heroes that power
broker made were playing on already
established ones
in the comics maelys recreates the
falcon and we also see in the show that
the new captain america has become a
commodity
with several action figures and products
now jackson eventually ended up using
the augmentation devices on himself
when he was attacked by a vigilante
known as the scourge of the underworld
curtis learned firsthand that calm as a
[ __ ] when he too faced the side effects
of the process
and this left him almost completely
paralyzed maelis took advantage of this
and sent in vagabond to steal his
fingerprints so that he could gain
access to all of jackson's accounts
this however failed and the power broker
power broke his legs
for betraying him shortly after though
he rehired him to help cure his
condition
and from here on out they had an uneasy
alliance now the power broker could
easily be curtis jackson
no not him man however come on and there
is a high possibility that he could be
revealed as a shady businessman
running things behind the scenes this
would fit in well with the location of
madrapua
which we learn is divided into two
sections just like how it is in the
comics
lowtown is a haven for crimes like
murders and narcotics
whereas hightown is reserved for things
like dodgy art dealings
which we'll talk about later in the
video it's not personal there
strictly business and therefore jackson
would fit in well with the aesthetic
the genetic experimentation also fits in
well with his origins in general mo
and add to that us agent and you have a
series of things that seem to be
pointing in the direction of it probably
being him
however if you've been following our
breakdowns then you'll know that we've
also theorized quite a lot that it might
actually be maelys behind it all
this is because in the comic book run
sam wilson captain america
he appears as the first major villain
the disney plus series is heavily based
on this book
and in it we see sam struggling with
taking on the mantle of captain america
and all that comes with it he also ends
up gaining joaquin torres as a sidekick
teams up with the winter soldier faces
down against us
agent and also the flag smasher now flag
smasher
is just a life model decoy in that but
even so there are a lot of similarities
in that malice is carrying out
experiments on people in order to make
them animal human hybrids
and though this isn't present in the
show his ties to power broker
incorporated do seem to line up
and there was also a second iteration of
the power broker called power broker 2
who became the latest owner of the
incorporated company
responsible for giving the character
hardball his powers
he's also capable of firing energy bolts
from his hands
and whenever we see him he appears in a
battle suit now for the moment none of
these characters are in the mcu at all
and there haven't been any leaks or cast
lists that seem to indicate they're in
the series
even if they were we also what happened
with james spader being listed as
playing ultron and one division
so for the moment we can't trust
anything that's online until we see the
show for ourselves
the series is clearly focused around the
power broker and the super soldier serum
and whereas in civil war we saw that the
formula could turn people crazy
it's now been refined to create more
grounded superhumans
now huge shout outs to screen crush for
unearthing an interview with series
writer derek colstad
who stated that marvel were bringing
back some characters from earlier mcu
movies
and weaving them throughout the plot
lines in order to carry on seemingly
drop ones
this led ryan to theorize that the
leader could be returning
and he definitely fits the mould of a
super intelligent character
that could be controlling things from
behind the scenes whereas hulk got super
strength
the leader got super intelligence and
due to him already being a character
that's carried out human experiments in
order to try and unleash
and tap potential he does line up quite
a lot with what we know about the power
broker
similar to how ross has returned and is
now playing a big part in the mcu
the leader could too and though this fan
theory is pretty unlikely
i actually think that it works really
well now the big theory that's going
around at the moment
is that sharon carter is actually the
power broker and they've done somewhat
of a gender swap
it's enough to break her poor old
auntie's heart but let's look through
the evidence and weigh up
whether we think she is or not when were
reintroduced to her she's operating in
high town as a stolen art stealer
and throughout the series we discover
that she's been on the run since civil
war because she broke the sokovia
records
now an enemy of the state she's had to
relocate to madrapue
and lives under the gumption that the
hero lifestyle she once saw after
was all a lie so she does have the right
mind state
and operation area to potentially be a
candidate
whatever way you look at it she's not
the same character that we last saw in
civil war
and clearly has people working for her
as underlings
now in the episode sam bucky and zemo
try and gain information on a scientist
named nagel
from an information broker called selby
his location is apparently extremely
hard to come by
and yet somehow later in the episode
sharon is able to gain it from one of
the guests at her party
now this may have simply been because
they were besotted by zemo's dance moves
or potentially sharon already knew where
he was
when they arrive at the location she
stays outside
and takes out all the gods that show up
going completely atomic blonde on them
she seems genuinely angry that zemo
decided to take nagel out
and if she were the power broker then
this would make a lot of sense
from here on she decides to remain in
madrapura and then goes and meets her
driver who says that they have some big
problems now whilst this theory
does have some things that make it seem
like it could be true
there's also a lot that contradicts it
firstly
we know that the power broker is someone
that doesn't like to get their hands
dirty
and i can't see sharon putting herself
in the line of fire if she was indeed
one in the same
she also never had any interest in
genetic augmentation
and it would also break her poor old
auntie's heart
surely if she was the power broker too
she would enter the container to keep a
close eye on what nagel was saying
and there's absolutely no way she would
allow him to be killed if he really was
paramount to her operations
sharon also seems desperate to get a
pardon i think that someone is high up
as the power broker
would likely have little interest in
seeking out returning to a conventional
life
got a big problem thus i think that this
big problem scene
is simply a red herring and that sharon
at best
is probably working alongside the power
broker in some form things just don't
line up and the use of the word him
whenever the power broker is brought up
makes it seem unlikely marvel have a
habit of doing this and as we saw with
one division
just because a character seems to say
something it doesn't mean anything at
all
you're not gonna die me again yet you're
not getting me with that bloody dotty
thing again
now strangely zemo describes the power
broker as him
despite being confined to a cell since
the events of civil war
we do see that he has a god card and it
is possible that he may even be the
villain
operating from his prison and sending
things out into the world
i think that's pretty unlikely but i
just thought i'd cover it as
i know a couple of people have mentioned
it in comments on my videos
overall though i would love to see the
leader rise up and be revealed as the
villain
however i do think that they might do
something similar to the comics
and unveil a brand new character namely
curtis jackson
yes that one now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts and theories below
on who you think the power broker really
is as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league on 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the third episode which will be linked
on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want more marvel
stuff to watch
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul
and this is between you all see you next
time goodbye